John Wick chapter 4 is finally here and
we've got some questions who is the
harbinger what's the deal with Winston
and could this really be the end for
everyone's favorite assassin the
shocking end of John Wick chapter 3 saw
Winston shoot John Wick right off the
roof of the Continental when John sees
Winston again in chapter 4 however he
doesn't seem to have a problem with him
so here's a question when Winston shot
John was he really shooting to kill
Winston knows the high table doesn't
pull his punches when it comes to
punishment so at tracks that he really
did try to kill John to meet the table's
demands of course it also tracks that
Winston knows his way around a
bulletproof suit he's also more than
aware that Jon can take a hit and fall
off a building without going down for
the count very well gentlemen
the Continental will now be
reconsecrated there is also a clear bond
between the two men and Winston even
seems paternal towards John at times you
can't tell but think that he shot Jon to
save his life rather than end it high
table be damned for all of Winston's
talk about rules being what keeps a man
separate from the animals he can't help
being a man of instinct himself while he
defers to top dogs are the adjudicator
Winston stops at nothing to protect the
rest of his pack even if he isn't always
successful
John Wick sets out to bring down the
high table in John Wick chapter four but
he doesn't start in New York instead he
heads to Morocco to chase down the new
Elder but why does Jon kill this elder
in the third installment of the John
Wick franchise Jon spends an eternity
walking through the desert to find the
Elder John's Hope is that this
mysterious figure will reinstate him to
the Assassin's Guild the Elder demands
Jon's ring finger in exchange for
removing the price tag on his head in
chapter 4 John is back in the desert
ready to kill the second Elder for not
being able to give him back the wedding
ring the old Elder Turk the new Elder
clearly doesn't know how to read the
room and tells Jon Hill only know peace
when he's dead this leads to Jon killing
him and sends a high table into
punishment hyperdrive while this Kill
Shot sets off the event of the movie it
also speaks to the series tragic Arc of
Revenge the Elder has been replaced by a
new Elder the Marquita groman will be
replaced by a new Marquee no matter how
many Hydra heads or henchmen John Wick
takes down new ones will spring back up
in their place ready for a new fight
with the same old John Wick
the John Wick films are stuffed with
symbolism poured from Greek and Roman
mythology it's a little weird then that
Winston recalls the Mythic last words of
a legendary Australian Outlaw in John
Wick's Last Ride Winston tells Sharon
that after hearing he was to be executed
the infamous Australian Bandit Ned Kelly
said such is life clearly these words
mean something to Winston to him Ned's
acceptance of his fate was Noble yet
unsettling Winston isn't ready to accept
the fates handed to him and his beloved
Continental from the high table however
nor does he accept that John Wick should
go down without a fight Jerome then
utters the same phrase to win Simba for
accepting his own face even if audiences
are shocked to see the Marquee finish
your own off this moment makes Winston
realize that the high table will always
take more than he can give
when the harbinger rolls up to the NYC
Continental he is clearly ready to get
down to business but why is he missing a
finger and why does that missing fingers
nub suspiciously swim with John Wicks
did the harbinger try and fail to get
out of the high table game just like
John Wick is there some other reason he
needed to cut off a finger to prove his
loyalty to the table The Harbinger
doesn't seem to take much pleasure in
enforcing the rules unlike the smuggly
evil Marquee however he doesn't back
down from his duties or try to get
creative with the rules unlike Winston
himself so what's the story this man's
backstory is one of the biggest
unanswered questions in John Wick
chapter 4. the harbinger's secret is all
in his name Harbinger is another word
for a warning of watches to come
basically he is John Wick's Ghost of
Christmas Yet to Come made flesh here to
show John what he could become if he
can't escape the high table The
Harbinger was likely once an assassin
just like John Wick one who judging from
his demeanor and Telltale finger lived
through a similar story yet suffered a
very different fate
obsessed with maintaining the supremacy
of the high table the villainous Marquis
De gramats agrees to John Wick's terms
for an old rules door and then quickly
begins to cheat he UPS the bounty on
John Wick's head and sends his own
assassins after him the Marquee
obviously has endless riches at his
disposal but what's his story why does
he have so much power and so little
Integrity the Marquis De gramand
represents how the high table's absolute
power leads to Absolute corruption he
worships the etiquette and ceremony of
the high table he is happy to exact the
pounds of Flesh and pints of blood from
those underneath him when they break the
rules but when it's his time to face the
music he chooses a proxy to fight for
him and still tries to cheat his way to
Victory the Marquee is both a
delightfully hateable villain and a
cautionary Tale in the wick verse his
power is orderly But ultimately corrupt
superficial and Hollow he demonstrates
the dangers of standing on ceremony
instead of principle and favoring
excessive shows of power over actual
skill and thus in the end is his
downfall
they gave you my name
yeah in chapter 4 the blind assassin
Kane is pressed into service to the high
table where the Marquis De gramand Kane
will do anything to keep his daughter
alive well I'm playing violin in the
Public Square even if that means killing
old friend John Wick so how does he
actually manage this okay so this is
less a statement of confusion than it is
an appreciation of Kane's creative and
Relentless fighting style for example
the slice of Kane's cane against glass
and steel is a compelling indicator of
the pain he's about to rain down on his
opponents meanwhile Kane's heightened
sense of hearing helps him locate John
Wick using the crunching glass on the
galleries scene at the Osaka Continental
however one of Kane's most unique
techniques involves the use of cleverly
placed doorbell sensors at first as
puzzling to see Kane slap a bunch of
electronic rectangles on various
surfaces in the Osaka continental's dark
kitchen it almost looks like he's
setting bomb charges but he isn't he's
just setting traps when the high table
Stormtroopers invade the kitchen they
set off the doorbell sensors and give
Kane a precise audible Target what a
badass
after John Wick kills the Elder he seeks
Refuge at Osaka's Continental in the
neon last night John Wick seeks help
from yet another Stern but loving
assassin Hotel manager shimazu Koji John
Wick chapter 4 implies that John shamazu
and Kane are old assassin friends so why
does Kane attack John Wick while shimazu
risks everything to protect him the
answer is simple for shimazu friendship
is a matter of the heart and when you're
in his heart your family Kane draws a
line between friend and family to
protect his daughter his daughter means
more to him than his friendship with
John Wick and he refuses to defy the
high table because he knows they will
kill her if he doesn't kill John Wick to
Mazu meanwhile knows the table will come
for him and his daughter Akira merely
for harboring John Wick in their Hotel
tomasu fights just as hard for John Wick
as he does for his daughter but it's his
choice to be loyal to his loved ones
ultimately costs him his life then again
considering the movie's post-credits
scene it's possible that Kane's choices
will do the same for him
there are two things a marquee loves
more than anything in this world sparkly
suits and sending messages the Marquis
sends plenty of the latter after John
Wick defies the high table including
killing pyoita leader of the ruska Roma
to punish the crime family for Jon's
actions pyota might not ring any bells
with viewers although he is an
off-camera adoptive father figure to Jon
from back in his jadani jovanovich days
the director is a Rusk Aroma character
that audiences are more likely to
remember still the death of pyotir has
left a bad taste in Nebraska Roma
family's mouth and Jon's adoptive sister
Katya won't help John by sponsoring his
door the Marquee unless he kills an
enemy of hers kilohocken it looks like
we have ourselves a
if Jon kills his boss he gets branded
back into the Roma family for a seat at
the table and a sanctioned shot of
Freedom by way of dueling the Marquee
Mr Nobody is one of the franchises
mysterious newcomers appearing out of
nowhere as a fully fledged adversary to
Mr Wick versus this man with a plan John
Wick's Friend or Foe at first Mr Nobody
appears to be yet another long-lost
friend of Jon emerging from the Shadows
to pledge his sword and attack dog to
the course he fires a shot that saves
Jon's life but it isn't because he
shares shimazu's brotherly love for John
nobody is trying to drive the price up
on Jon's head not save it from Rolling
while you can totally imagine a universe
in which Mr Nobody and jump buddy up or
even one where nobody finds a fist full
of reasons to take up Jon's fight
against a high table by the end of the
film Nobody is pursuing a 40 million
dollar payday that would pay for a whole
lot of cargo pants sure but why does he
really need that much well Shamir
Anderson recently told inverse isn't
nobody that needs the cash at all he
said not a giveaway too much but it was
for his mother
John Wick chapter 4 seems to kill off
John Wick for good after taking hits
after hits and stare fall after Starfall
John seems to meet his end on the steps
of sakurakure he slumps his side in the
sunrise enjoying one last version of the
wife he lost later the Bowery King and
Winston visit John's grave he's buried
next to his wife and even though the two
visitors were a little light-hearted
with their farewells John Stone is
inscribed as he requested so is this a
clever setup for an impossible beginning
in John Wick chapter 5 or is it really
the end Atomic movies are such stunning
spectacles that is easy to forget how
much effort time and talent they take to
make four years passed between the
release of John Wick chapter 3 and his
follow-up film and Keanu Reeves and Chad
stahlski have plenty on their plates
aside from the world of work the
collaborators have been working together
in one way or another since their Matrix
days who knows what their creative
partnership might yield if this is the
end of John Wick's Road although it
seems like the character will make an
appearance in a ballerina spin-off movie
it really does seem like everyone's
favorite dog avenging grave-stricken
husband might be gone for good such is
life
foreign